you
patta stay motivated when you look at
people who are successful you will find
that they aren't the people who are
motivated but have consistency in their
motivation being an entrepreneur sucks a
lot of the time it's hard to stay
motivated you might have a fantastic day
be on top of the world and then the next
one and wake up and find you're starting
from scratch you're doing something
different so if they knew something
powerful and it takes time to make it
happen you might have a little man in
your life telling you all the reasons
why you're not going to be successful
you might not be seeing any growth of
our men Simmons you struggle to find
your way you might even be thinking of
going back to get a job but do the same
thing to support your family men it's
hard trying to stay motivated as an
entrepreneur but you know what helps
feeling like you're doing something
important that's what people really want
out of life that's probably what you
hated about your last job who wanted to
wake up and feel like the work you are
doing was important when you get that
feeling you're more likely to stay
motivated and that comes from finding
your one word and applying it to make a
positive impact on the world
[Music]
you
you